I've got a red flag comes up if any man
calls himself a feminist but I do know
some good men who have done that and
said it in public and been slighted for
it rightly with this part of M brain
rightly but I'm thinking what's what now
though was the after care what can I do
so I try and how do we keep him on track
as well just because he he slipped up
how do we still keep him yeah cuz I
think some of them come to it from the
point that feminism isn't a dirty word
it's a good thing therefore I should
support it therefore I'm going to put my
name to it and not have the thought
process of actually whose is this thing
so it's not ours and I think if any if
any men are watching this who are in
that space I would just put it this way
really is if we cannot hear the women
who say feminism is ours and it's not
yours then if we continue to say that I
am that or I'm part of it then that is
an aggressive act